[Musique]
ce mercredi 31 août le président du
département était en déplacement à saint
louis pour la signature du pacte de
solidarité territoriale deuxième
génération avec la mère juliana m
doihoma le pst c est un partenariat
départements communes instauré il ya
maintenant trois ans visant le
développement l'aménagement et
l'amélioration du cadre de vie des
habitants ce dispositif ayant fait ses
preuves le département souhaite
renouveler son soutien aux communes à
travers le pst 2 comme c'était le cas ce
mercredi dans la commune du sud un
travail d'écouté et de dialogue qui se
concrétise à travers plusieurs axes
c'est un plaisir pour avoir du théâtre
aujourd'hui
eh bien je suis à saint louis
aux côtés de la mère juliana reine doit
au va et de toute son équipe il faut
concrétiser donc des actions que nous
avons engagées avec la municipalité de
saint-louis service est une belle
commune et c'est une commune qui doit
être accompagnée et le départ de voir
les là pour aider la commune et des
habitants de saint-louis dans le domaine
de l'action sociale dans le domaine de
la position écologie et coire divers
aménagements l'action sociale c'est quoi
c'est de les familles défavorisées
amélioration de l'habitat
l'accompagnement les livraisons de repas
pour les gramounes
pour paf à les isoler et donc la commune
de saint louis a beaucoup de projets
comme ça et nous les l'avoir accompagné
cette belle ville et puis le plan un
million d'arbres le verdissement de
toute la réunion protéger notre nature
d'entre eux environnement et ben là
aussi la ville de saint louis fait
beaucoup d'action et le départ moyenne
aux autres et enfin tout ce qui est
aménagements nous narre des travaux
routiers avec les radiers qu'on est en
train de faire en sorte qu'il y ait de
moins en veine ratier dangereux pour la
population de la région est bien sûr ici
à celui qui à l'orée du bois qui est
bien dans le département veut faire des
travaux coiffeur devils il voyait un peu
sur le voie qui offre la rivière
saint-louis et saint-pierre et ce
contrat sera réalisé par le département
de la veille nous les la fois pour
prendre la ville nous les lavoirs
convaincre la population
nou lé là pour faire de la proximité
pour faire reculer la misère c'est ça le
travail que la mairie de saint yves est
il des paroles hélas un côté pour la
période 2021 2023 le département alou
pour le dispositif pst2 une enveloppe
totale de 100 millions d'euros pour les
24 communes dont 4,6 millions sont
attribués à saint louis saint louis est
une ville qui avec l'engagement de mon
équipe est en plein éveil mais ça lui
est une ville qui a aussi et surtout
besoin de partenaires solides comme le
département de la réunion pour nous
aider à travailler à concrétiser tous
les projets qu'on a besoin pour
améliorer le quotidien de la population
et le département et à ce niveau là la
collectivité la plus appropriée puisque
c'est elle qui a en charge du social et
que saint louis malheureusement se
distingue par des indicateurs sociaux
alarmant c'est ce pour quoi nous avons
ce matin acté le plan de solidarité
territoriale sur le volet social avec
des actions classiques comme l'aide
alimentaire le portage de repas mais
aussi avec des actions innovantes qui
vont arriver et il ya aussi et surtout
un grand travail avec le département et
une convention qui a été signée sur le
volet investissement puisqu'on a un
territoire qui souffre d'un déficit
d'infrastructures et d'équipements
publics et aujourd'hui grâce à l'aide du
département nous avons pu accélérer un
certain nombre de choses qui relèvent de
notre propre projet de mandature comme
la modernisation des routes autre moment
fort de la visite du jour la signature
du plan un million d'arbres qui se
concrétisera dans la commune avec la
plantation de plus de quarante six mille
individus jusqu'en 2026 et la création
de micro forêt le président du
département et la maire de saint louis
ont poursuivi leur journée sur le
terrain avec une visite des sites ou des
chantiers sont en passe d'être lancés ou
au lieu-dit 3 ravine les élus ont pris
connaissance du projet d'aménagement de
la rue général de gaulle
s'en est suivi un détour vers le radier
du ouaki où le projet de réalisation
d'un ouvrage de franchissement a été
présenté
[Musique]
enfin cyril mail qui aura suivi juliana
m doihoma au terrain borie dans le
quartier du gol les hauts ou a été
dévoilé le programme ambitieux
d'aménagement du terrain
[Musique]